hey guys my name is Jess it is Monday
the sixteenth of November you're
watching games but news and I've been
awake for over 24 hours doing an extra
life marathon live stream so let's see
how this goes Lori those may not have
even released uncharted 4 yet but
they've come out to say that they have
at least one and maybe more games in the
works for the playstation 4 community
strategist on Maya was interviewed by
finder a financial planning site of all
things and was quizzed about Nintendo's
NX console and the next generation of
consoles after the ps4 xbox one and Wii
U when asked whether Naughty Dog's next
game would make it during this current
generation he said I would hope we would
release a game pretty soon our
development cycles aren't too long and I
have no idea how long this console
generation really is going to last but
yeah there's no doubt it should be in
this console generation for sure clearly
we can release a game really late in the
console generation and do well right
Maya was likely referring to the last of
us which came towards the end of the
ps3's lifecycle and was subsequently
remastered for ps4 soon after in
September of this year Naughty Dog
creative director Neil druckmann
revealed that a prototype for the last
of his two had been made I was not
currently in development at due to
development on uncharted 4 next up
fighting games aren't generally known
for featuring incredible narratives but
Street Fighter thoth may be planning to
turn that all around by including an
elaborate origin story with their
tutorial mode although street fighter 5
features much older versions of the
iconic world warriors many of whom now
sport grey hair and fears capcom
released a video of the game's tutorial
mode which features a much much younger
Ryu and Ken the two rivals appear as
they did in the street fighter alpha
series which acted at the prequel and
the tutorials story depicts them
training with them master gouken who
appeared in Street Fighter 4 although it
would make sense that these younger
character models would be usable in
natchez outside the tutorial Capcom has
not officially confirmed this street
fighter 5 is due for release in February
2016 and most recently produced
Oh No teased six new downloadable
characters at paris games week finally
and in what appears to be the most
exciting story of today you can now
remap your controllers buttons on the
xbox one put the recent launch of the
new xbox one experience microsoft have
introduced the ability to reassign the
standard xbox one controllers buttons on
a system level however this
customization isn't as robust for the
standard controller as it is for the
recently released $150 Xbox one elite
controller in a recent blog post
Microsoft's Major Nelson explained if
you want the Y button to serve as the X
button the X button will then
automatically begin to serve as the x
button but there's no way to remove an
input from the controller or have
multiple buttons all do the same thing
both of which are possible within a late
unfortunately the current limitations
mean that these configurations are at a
system based levels so you can't save
different load outs for different games
and the settings are saved to the local
console meaning you can't take your
configurations with you to another
console or like the elite controller
button remapping for regular xbox one
controllers is also currently
unavailable for pete's sake but the
ability to do so is quote to be
confirmed at a later time let me know
down in the comments what you think of
remapping buttons as a feature and if
it's important to you you can add a game
swap we've got stories on Nintendo
winning legal battles against three dias
piracy and plenty of awesome gaming
deals that is everything a happy today I
am going to go get some serious sleep
but I will see you all here same time
tumor
you